welcome back my beloved weebs today
we're going to talk about an anime
series called magi adventure of sinbad
which is an adventure fantasy anime with
a great storyline without any further
ado let's dive right into it on the
night of a ferocious storm bada an
ex-war hero helps his wife through a
difficult birth different mages all
around the world take notice of the flow
of rook in their respective part of the
world and surmise that a great power has
just been brought into the world badla's
wife successfully gives birth to a
healthy baby boy they name him sinbad
the man who will eventually rule the
seven seas
years later in a village lying within
the great pantavia empire soldiers
celebrate their victory at the local pub
while bardo tries to enjoy a drink as
well soldiers arrive to pay him for his
great service in the war however he
refuses claiming he has no use for a
fortune he doesn't agree with the
nation's aggressive expansion efforts
and just wants to focus on fishing two
years later bartavian soldiers chased a
soldier from rem off a cliff the next
morning in a different area sinbad's
father continues to work as an honest
fisherman
angry citizens confront barbara calling
him a traitor and demanding to stop
fishing in that area in the past two
years partavia has gone to war with rem
its citizens are slowly descending into
poverty and all of them are desperate to
win the war to re-obtain their wealth
these people attack badr who simply
lasts them off and allows himself to be
beaten in front of his son when he
awakens he tries to ignore it but sinbad
is infuriated that his father didn't
defend himself and runs off that night
at dinner sinbad quickly finishes his
food and runs off to draw water from a
well sinbad returns bringing an injured
man with him the same man who was being
chased by bartavian soldiers earlier
sinbad's family nurses this man back to
health and he eventually awakens he
thanks sinbad for saving him and
introduces himself as darius a traveling
merchant claiming to be shipwrecked
father offers his help one morning
darius attempts to leave while simbad's
mother attempts to serve him some food
they're interrupted when soldiers
suddenly arrive and tell her they've
been looking for a spy in the area they
force their way into the house and are
brutally murdered by darius he takes
sinbad hostage to keep all the citizens
away from him sinbad doesn't understand
what's happening but darius reveals he's
a spy from rem he demands a boat and
money in return for sinbad just before
the spy escapes with the child bada
arrives to stop him he gets on his knees
and begs him to let sinbad go he
suggests darius should change sides and
provide information to bartavia but this
only serves to anger darius a proud
citizen of rem in an instant while he's
distracted barther stabs him in the
heart with a knife he takes back sinbad
and declares that he doesn't care what
people say about him but he'll never
forgive anyone who harms his family
afterward badr is charged with the crime
of harboring a spy and is sent off to
fight in the war while simbad and his
mother cried and plead with the guards
to stop villagers demand their family to
leave the village immediately as badr
leaves sinman behind he tells him he'll
have to fight like a man throughout his
life and are sinbad to take care of his
mother this experience helps zinbad
realize his father's strength a few
moments later badr is killed on the
battlefield and his sword is sent back
home nine years later sinbad has grown
into a teenager the world's changed very
much as mysterious buildings and
structures are appearing all over the
world people begin to call them dungeons
because they hold immense treasures and
powers a dungeon also appears in the
partavia empire the empire ordered an
army of 10 000 people to seize the
dungeon but none of them came back alive
at the port some girls are traveling to
sell fresh fruits but they're stopped by
thugs sinbad comes in and saves them by
beating the crap out of these thugs the
girls give him some fruits as a gift
upon opening the barrel of fruit a man
is found there he gets surprised and
closes the barrel telling them not to
open it without permission afterwards
sinbad takes him back to his town
the man reveals himself to be a
traveller named yunnan upon asking he
tells him that he likes to live in small
cramped spaces and the barrel was a
perfect place for him yunnan continued
to observe him and later sinbad takes
him to his house in the morning sinbad
makes breakfast for unite and leaves for
his duty soon after sinbad's mother
wakes up and struggles with her disease
yoonan gives her water she begins to
tell him that sinbad is bound to this
town because of her although he has a
special power even his father used to
say that he'll become a ruler in the
future she ends the talk by requesting
unite to guide him whenever he's in
trouble he witnesses rook flowing from
her and gets surprised upon seeing him
suddenly a woman comes in and tells him
the army is beating sinbad because he
didn't join them even after several
official letters dragul the commander of
a small squad orders sinbad to join he
refuses by saying that joining the army
for war is just cruelty as the army is
just using them as tools the people of
the town join simbad and tell them to go
away as they'll not tolerate them
anymore dragon leaves saying if he
doesn't join the army then his mother
will be considered a traitor just like
his father afterward sinbad is wrapping
bandages on his wounds while talking
with yunan he tells him that going to
the dungeon is like suicide because no
one's ever come back from it he's in
trouble because even if he doesn't join
the army then they'll kill him for
treason yunnan advises him to conquer
the dungeon to become a king as he has
the potential to become a king sinbad
asks him about his identity but he
disappears saying he's just a traveler
sinbad swears to capture and sees the
power of the dungeon so that he can
change the world for the better back at
home his mother gives him the sword left
by his father and tells him he should go
on an adventure he doesn't need to worry
about her as she'll be fine in imperial
castle dragon gets the order to conquer
the dungeon at all costs the next day
dragon reaches the gate of the dungeon
with his army as they're about to charge
in sinbad appears and tells them that
he'll conquer the power of this dungeon
and will never let them have it yoonan
tells him that he can't come back unless
he's conquered the dungeon sinbad makes
his resolve and charges inside dragon
also charges him with his army too
yunnan wonders what will simba do after
acquiring the power upon entering the
dungeon simbad's surprised to see the
world inside it which is completely
different and full of mythical creatures
their sinbad is attacked by small
dragons but he brilliantly evades them
dragol is struggling against the dragons
his entire army is wiped out in an
instant he's cornered by a dragon but
sinbad saves him by killing the dragon
with a spear suddenly a giant dragon
passes by and they're forced to hide
from him to survive the dungeon they end
up forming an unlikely alliance for the
time being they find the door right
behind the dragon's dim
drago leaves on his own to find a way to
the door he encounters random geezers
and baby dragons on his way upon
reaching the door he tries to unlock it
but it's all in vain the dragon king
notices his presence and charges his
lightning breath while draggle struggles
to escape just when the dragon was about
to kill him sinbad saves him and takes
him away drago says that he's failed as
a soldier and he should die but sinbad
consoles him and says that there's
nothing to be ashamed about he takes the
shield of dragon and heads for the
dragon he uses the shield as a surfboard
to ride the water waves from the giza he
strikes the dragon while surfing and
lands a final blow on his face sinbad
succeeds in killing the monster and two
ball-like keys appear they use the keys
to open the door they continue their
adventure while killing random monsters
appearing along the way drago is
impressed by the abilities and actions
of simbad upon reaching the final door
they have a small humorous fight like
always and then proceed to enter the
room simbad finds a lamp and touches it
and suddenly a big jin emerges from the
lamp he asks who will become the king as
both of them seek power for their own
reasons they decide to settle the winner
with a deadly match sinbad attacks him
with his sword but dragon evades the
attack soon drago gets the upper hand
and he's more skilled with swords he
pins down sinbad and lands a strike but
sinbad stops him with his hands and then
lands a solid punch on his face throwing
him away despite losing all his strength
he comes again to attack sinbad only to
get beaten up again he gathers his
remaining strength and dashes towards
sinbad for the final blow sinbad emerges
victorious in the battle barn forms a
contract with him and dwells in his
sword suddenly all the items in the room
turn to gold and the dungeon disappears
indicating that the first dungeon has
been conquered upon waking sinbad finds
himself with tons of gold around him the
army approaches him and orders him to
hand over the power and wealth to them
sinbad tells them that he'll not give
anything to the cruel empire anymore
yunnan makes an appearance and tells
sinbad to use his new power he calls for
the jinn from his sword and lightning
falls on the army around him yoonan uses
his magic that ends up taking simbad and
his wealth back to his hometown right
after reaching the town he gets news
about his mother's bad condition and
rushes towards home upon reaching he
grabs his mother's hand her condition is
so bad that she mistook him for bad she
tells him that she will soon join him
sinbad breaks into tears his mother dies
while saying that she'll always love
sinbad on the other hand dragul in a
wounded state walks around the palace
sinbad gets famous all over the empire
since the capture of the first dungeon
more dungeons are appearing in all parts
of the world many people challenge them
and some even manage to clear them
simbad is travelling as usual on his way
he finds a big guy with a girl trying to
capture a large water dragon the big guy
attacked the dragon with a harpoon but
the outer shell of the dragon was so
strong that the harpoon couldn't pierce
it to save his drowning sister he dives
into the sea with a dragon chasing him
just when the dragon's about to eat them
sinbad uses the power of baal to fry the
dragon leaving the man in shock on the
other hand dragon is leading another
special squad to capture another dungeon
on the orders of the emperor he's given
another chance by his brother to steal
the jin power from sinbad to prove
himself the prideful soldier of the
pantavia empire he's given a special
squad called shamlaj to execute this
mission simbad and the man are now on
the shore igniting a fire to warm
themselves up the man's sister wakes up
and assumes her brother to be the one
who has defeated the water dragon the
man's name is hina they have a meal
together sinbad asks them about their
northern village to which they reply
it's covered with pure white snow and
their father is the patriarch of the
village despite knowing that the village
won't welcome him sinbad decides to
visit it because it will be his first
step towards changing the world on the
same night he apologizes to hina for
stealing his prey sinbad comments on his
strength and effort to save his sister
which surprises him upon reaching the
village sinbad is surprised to see the
strange houses in the village he meets
the father of hina who doesn't welcome
him the village prepares for a feast
because hina has finally proven himself
a warrior on the other hand the sorcerer
withdragal sent the assassin squad to
kill simbad back to the village hina's
father tells him about a dungeon that
recently appeared outside their village
he asks his son to accompany other
warriors to conquer it but sinbad
interrupts and warns them about it
because many people perish in dungeons
sinbad shows them his power which
surprises them hina's father
acknowledged him upon witnessing his
power sinbad enjoys the feasts with the
villagers while hina walks away in guild
because he didn't manage to kill the
dragon soon his sister accompanies him
and tells him that he should be happy
about becoming a warrior but it's all in
vain at night the commander of the
assassin squad attacks sinbad in his
sleep but ends up being electrocuted by
the lightning power of jinn sinbad tries
to question him but he refuses to answer
anything since he's a kid sinbad asks
him about his parents to which he boasts
that he killed them a long time ago upon
hearing this he slaps the kid for
boasting about such a tragic action he
escapes the house with the help of his
partners after that hina's sister comes
to sinbad and tells him that her brother
has left to conquer the dungeon on his
own
sinbad tells her that he'll save her
brother no matter what while leaving he
gives her a determined scary look to
show his commitment and resolve hina
enters the dungeon hoping that with his
power everyone will acknowledge him and
he'll be powerful like sinbad upon
entering he gets surprised to see the
mysterious world inside the dungeon
sinbad follows him into the dungeon
while yunnan watches from a distance
wondering if he's again attracted by the
power of the dungeon he now finds
butterflies gathering around him in the
dungeon but they turn out to be little
monsters attacking him upon looking
closer he quickly uses his harpoon to
fend them off a swarm of butterflies
surround him but he now dives into the
nearby river to get rid of them
fortunately he survives this deadly
attack after covering some more distance
inside the dungeon he discovers the gate
to the treasure room when he knows about
to reach the door suddenly a crab
monster attacks him and lands a slash on
his back he falls into the river with
the beast he now gathers all his
strength by reminding himself that he's
not a coward anymore and charges the
harpoon towards the crab monster after a
massive splash of water he throws the
beast out of the water and dashes
forward to land the final blow but the
assassins kill the monster before him
much to his dismay dragon and his team
take the crystal to open the treasure
room he now takes a stand for himself
and he tells him to give him the crystal
as he's the one who reached it first he
displays his insane strength and a fight
begins between them he now faces off
against the trio of assassins at first
he dominates the fighting but he gets
trapped in their combined attack just
when the lead is about to kill him
sinbad intervenes and uses the power of
baal to stop them drago greets him in
his usual sulking manner the mage with
dragon introduces herself as farlan the
leader of the assassin squad attack
sinbad as he's bent on killing him a
fight breaks again between them hina
gets dragged into this as well sinbad
tries to use his power but dragon
attacks him with a gun to stop him he
knight steps in and dives into the river
with sinbad to escape the scene farlan
uses her magic to freeze the river but
fortunately they survive it draggle
wonders about the real identity of this
mage she gives the team three magic
pills to boost their powers and after
taking the pills they feel much lighter
and more powerful draggle inserts the
crystal and walks into the treasure room
with its companions on the other hand
sinbad gets out from the freezing water
heena tells him he'll claim the
dungeon's power to which sinbad tells
him that he's already strong enough the
scene shifts to dragol who summoned the
jinn of the dungeon the jinn emerges
from the metal vessel and claims to be
the gin of deception and confidence he
recognizes the evil scent of fallen and
destroys her puppet doll dragon tells
the jin that he'll become king and he'll
give power to the majesty which bores
him to the point he turns into a cute
cat sinbad and hina reach the treasure
room jin presents them with a challenge
to catch a cat made from his blood they
all decide to claim the power for
themselves and dash forward to catch the
cat but the cat turns out to be very
fast much to their dismay after several
failed attempts sinbad asks them to work
together he manipulates them by telling
them he won't participate in the
combined attack the cat jumps when they
dash towards her and simba quickly
catches it they lash at him calling him
a traitor but sinbad makes an exciting
speech that must claim this power to
change the world and he'd love to have
all of them as his followers they end up
getting passionate after listening to
his speech after all simbad is born to
lead people as a king the assassin squad
suddenly goes berserk because of the
magic pills given to them by far land
they become a source of black power that
summons a giant demon dragon tries to
kill them but sinbad stops him because
he wants to save them the demon attacks
them with his massive power leaving
simbad injured hina and drago step in to
stop the demon but it's all in vain jin
reveals that they can save them if they
manage to destroy the demon's heart in a
single attack sinbad lands an attack on
the demon but farlan in his illusionary
body takes the sword of sinbad away to
prevent him from using jin's power hina
finally acknowledges sinbad as a
powerful man and declares him a king
vessel together they decide to unleash a
final attack simba dashes forward as a
decoy while hina charges his harpoon to
land the final blow however the demon
catches sinbad and makes him suffer
dragon lands an attack on the face of
the demon that helps sinbad to escape
finally hina unleashes his charged
harpoon which pierces the demon's heart
in a single go leaving fine and everyone
in shock sinbad takes advantage of this
moment to claim back his sword by
destroying the dollar farland however
the situation is unclear because the
assassin's leader's heart has fallen in
iniquity and the demon is using him to
revive himself simba takes the challenge
and tries to save him sinbad discovers
his memories of being forced into a
ruthless assassin upon holding his hand
sinbad finds him crying in his memories
because the organization forced him to
kill his parents sinbad saves him by
convincing him that they won't let
anyone use him in the future he uses the
power of baal to destroy the reviving
demon the assassin leader comes back
from depravity with the help of sinbad
that surprises everyone even jin they
all bow before simbad and tell him to
claim power because he is the true king
after forming a pact with jinn the
dungeon disappears and they all find
themselves back in the village dragon
leaves were saying he must save someone
in the empire while leaving drago
receives a portion of jin's power
because he's acknowledged sinbad as his
king hina decided to follow sinbad on
his journey as his follower they meet
the villagers founder who turns out to
be a giant furious man finally he now
gets permission from the chief and his
daughter becomes his wife
sinbad forms a diplomatic relationship
with hina's village that marks the
beginning of his future trade company
with two jin's powers in his hand what
will be the next destination of simbad
the future king of the seven seas
continue watching from episode seven to
discover more about the legendary
adventure of sinbad and his fellows so
that's it for today's video if you liked
the video give it a huge thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel for more anime
recaps farewell till the next video bye